[Music]
go okay hello everyone welcome to
my class
i welcome online audience in-person
audience which is very huge you can see
it but it's a lot of people here it's
crowded
uh
and today the topic is pawns
so we're gonna be talking about pawns
why they are powerful
so before we start with this game
actually let me
just go here because all i want to ask
you is why pawns are important
what are their roles in the chess game
so i'm going to give you some time and
just start talking
what makes bonds powerful or important
yep yeah you there
controlling squares very good so they
control squares
what else do they do
yep they can promote that's very
important yep
because when we want to study pawns we
really need to like
remember or understand all the aspects
all the dimensions that where they can
play a role so it's good kind of to you
know slow down at the beginning and just
acknowledge all that so control squares
promote
what else
do i have to refresh chat or just no one
is saying anything i'm gonna have to
give you a new link
okay i guess the only way to do that is
manual
oops
it's okay
so what else
are pawns doing
thank you
awesome so hello rob webster dmitry
james aryan oh i remember some names
from previous time
awesome so what
what makes spawn powerful all right so
let's see
uh
they are the souls of chess oh wow
that's very philosophical so how
how do they
exhibit or i don't know how to say that
but
maybe more practical thing but yeah
maybe soul of chess is great
okay pawn structure can be
the pawns are the structure in our army
okay but again a little bit more
specific if we can go
pawns determine the way you play
um okay i kind of have an idea which
very which way you want to go but i want
you to be more specific like controlling
squares or promoting what else can they
do
as offensive tool to gain control of
files and ranks yes very good so uh
like to maybe
control files so
how do we control files with the pawn
though
so maybe just open up space for like
pieces to
uh maybe control files or ranks
pawn chain pointing somewhere you might
want to attack there okay
very good so pawns can be very strong in
a pawn chain
what else i'm not gonna let you go that
easily there are still so many things
spawns do we didn't name
just try to imagine some kind of pawn
structure
um
ponds are spinning downward i don't know
what that means
triple pawns are an effective way to
control a file but there are downsides
yep if we have pawns in advance we could
have more space for our pieces very good
so gaining space
so pawns allow us to gain space because
the more we push them the more space
they're going to control but also behind
them we suddenly have more space for our
pieces
very good point angel
and if you have inferior structure you
got to be aggressive
so yeah if ponds can like make maybe our
position like very like crunched that we
we can be uncomfortable
what about some
offensive yeah
or any anything sorry
so they can kind of determine the way uh
we had with our position so let's say we
have knights we may choose with pawns to
kind of close the pawn structure so
again they control some squares and the
knights can go there
i also think about ponds as you know a
very cheap force or labor to like break
in somewhere
because like sacrificing a pawn like on
the king side you know like playing f6
as white or like like here f6 and
breaking like the pawn structure or
sometimes like h6 just giving up that
pawn to open up stuff
is very important
like you can almost like exploit the
fact that they aren't
because
because like like you said you know you
can
so we can help create a weakness like
trade pawns and suddenly the pawn is a
weakness
yep it determines whether bishop is bad
or good bones are also very good kind of
defensive force you know like these
pawns when we castle there the king is
very safe
right so you see that pawns can be very
good attacking forces like kind of for
defense
for gaining space
for controlling important squares um
what else for like pawns can easily like
sometimes we have a pawn here and like
let's say um
bishop and queen there like sometimes we
can easily clear a diagonal with pawns
awesome so keeping all that in mind
today i prepare a few positions where
we're gonna focus on how we play with
pawns
so let's move on now to this first
game
why to play here
this is a very nice instructive games
about how to be
playing with pawns
so take your time first to kind of
evaluate what is happening here
this looks like a very typical royal
lopez structure
what to do here
so black just played c5
and it's white's turn
okay some idea with knight f5 knight f1
i assume this one the typical kind of
maneuver
so we see that after c5 there is kind of
a lot of tension right all these bones
are
looking at each other
so we can maybe ignore it and like just
move back
but i would be careful because of the
new
no you can do that because you can yep
you're not losing anything
so any ideas what to
play here how to continue
okay we have d5 suggestion
so why d5
which seems like a natural thing
yep so in rural lopez we very often like
to close the center especially make this
bishop really bad and then potentially
we have this night jumping there or some
other stuff but like these pieces could
be looking at the
kind of kink side and attack there
potentially we also are very happy that
after d5
uh black cannot easily like push because
this knight is under attack it's pinned
so d5 is a good move here to play
immediately
but that did not happen in the game in
the game
white first took here
black took and then white decided to uh
to close the position
so what happened next
was black played knight
a4 the idea is to
attack kind of the pawn but also get
away from this so we can play c4
now white play this really important
move c4
so white is stopping black for moving
there and then you know potentially
reshuffling the knight there or
developing bishop to c5 by keeping the
pawn on c5 and kind of blocking
um
blocking this pawn there
so c5
c4
b4
okay so we have closed center really
nice pawns here this bishop is not great
um
i think white has a very comfortable
position this spawn also in the future
can be very dangerous for promotion
but how do we continue
what to do now
what did karpov choose to play here
and i would like you to think about like
two or three moves just to have some
options what we can do here
so you all online if you can just write
two or three move candidates that you
think are moves that are logical
you may choose later to play completely
different moves that's that's fine but
just right now what are moves that
seem you know kind of logical natural to
play in such position
i can kick it off with like queen c2
that seems logical because this move is
probably coming so queen c2 okay we just
move it first
all right what else
a3 idea with queen a2
okay good identic
corner wants to immediately crush the
center with f4
james knight f5 i mean all those moves
make sense
what else knight f3 queen b3 and knight
f1
yep
also
uh i mean i understand that you want to
bring the king towards the center i also
understand the knight f1 is kind of a
logical um not logical but very often
like a maneuver you do in this position
i'm not sure where exactly though you
are going with this knight because both
these squares are taken but it's a move
that you know like we consider
knight b3
okay
bishop c2
so what about here any other ideas
i mean a lot of moves were said already
okay
so i think like queen c2 for me makes a
lot of sense knight f5 and i also like
your f4 ideas
but you know what is really important to
kind of think in chess is and especially
what grandmasters do like karpov they
don't rush with things so if you are
happy with your pawn structure and you
know you want to attack on the king side
you prepare things
so karpov played move that was not
mentioned yet
knight e2 okay maybe preparing f4
good idea and also stopping this knight
after this going here
did not happen
what is a good preparatory move
for this position
okay i'll give five more seconds
go for it quickly
make a guess
queen a1 suggested okay
yes
shilaj is getting the trophy rook f1
you are so close
rook f1 so we do want to go with f4 but
we are preparing it because obviously if
the f file opens we want to have the
rook there
and this rook uh
is just not that like helpful and i know
a lot of you are suggesting like knight
b3 or even like a3 and this and that but
i don't think white wants to play on the
queen size right now white really wants
to focus on the king side
so rook f1 happened
black played
c7
white
start
f4
now capturing out f4 is really really
problematic because it opens up the
bishop
and if you want it to be like okay i'm
going to trade it now the problem is
that now this knight is going to jump
here
and this queen is trouble we may be
threatening knight take h6
and if you go somewhere like
uh let's say queen d8 so you are still
defending the knight and there is no
knight take h6 tactics
i may just go
i think what like queen b3 there
there
then just think about yeah i think i
think that's what i would do
and the problem is that just these
spawns are gonna come they're gonna go
there and just gonna be very very
dangerous
so
just capturing the pawn seems a little
tricky
so what black decided was knight d7
so black is getting ready that if white
takes black is going to capture with the
knight keeping kind of the blockade here
and with this knight on e5 i think black
is kind of surviving and being happy the
bishop is still controlling those pawns
so black is secured
but obviously as white we don't want to
capture right now when black is prepared
for the capture we are not going to do
that
so white played queen c2 improving the
queen
knight c3
and now white decided to close it
f5
so f5 um
we may think about like pushing f6 at
some moment we are just like threatening
but honestly when i saw this game i
didn't understand much what is happening
but after you see the whole game then
you kind of see you know it's like steve
jobs says right you connect the dots
looking for looking backward so the same
thing like it doesn't have to make too
much sense for you now but i recommend
maybe looking at this game after this
session again because then you will
understand every single move and that's
what it's about like when you are
studying from like strong red masters
like karpov because you may not get the
idea immediately but then everything
kind of connects and makes a really nice
picture
so f5 knight f6
but this is the moment i want you to
think
because for me this movie is like
it may not be too hard to find
actually i showed this to this like one
kid recently and he suggested it pretty
fast but i think
it's like strategic move what to do here
for white
so again like look at this don't we just
like throwing
uh
moves but think about what makes sense
and think about three moves again
two three moves
and then
zoom in on one of them
oh thank you edwin
okay knight h1 that's very creative
what's the idea
knight b1
you know kasper of hezeraku ruled like
he always says uh
i think it was
like never go backwards with your knight
i think we are kind of breaking it here
but i understand your moves uh the idea
behind those moves and i think they are
good i just want you to spell out those
ideas so knight h1 in order to go
to g5
how do you get the knight there
okay so someone is suggesting this way
okay by the way i'm super happy that
move candidates are coming
okay i see a lot of you are seeing that
move that i was very uh
very kind of
impressed by
oh okay so with the ponder
got it so knight h1 would be pushing the
pawn good idea i think we will have like
a small twist to that
okay g4 okay so maybe this yep that
makes sense what karpov decided to play
here is the move that many of you
suggested super cool knight e2 so
basically in this position
i'll tell you what i think that casper
karpov thought so he wants to move this
pawn forward because if we get pawn to
g5 it's just much easier to like break
in maybe we can have even h4 there to
support the the break
so that's one thing we want this pawn to
go forward and we are not to worry about
opening up our king
because
look at these pieces here like they're
just out of the picture even actually
this rock
maybe like actually all of the black
species are like we don't care if there
are like two open files because just
these pieces can never take part in any
attack
and secondly this is the only really
active piece that's actually kind of
annoying right if we are white this
knight can sometimes make some kind of
fork here it's attacking there maybe
sometimes sacrificing with pushing just
this knight is the only piece that's
like semi dangerous
so after knight e2 we just want to trade
it and we want to allow this
this pawn to fulfill its potential
okay so knight e2 knight takes
bishop takes
bishop d6 obviously just developing
and no time to waste g4 going for it
okay most of this game is really
interesting to be looking from the
white's perspective this is the only
situation that i'm gonna flip the board
here we go magic
and i want you to think what to play for
black
because white's plan is very simple here
here
and just checkmate you i don't even know
if maybe with the queen there somehow or
improving the knot sorry
night the mouse is so fast here
like good luck with that
so what are you going to do if you are
black here are just going to wait for a
slow death
are you going to be like you know crazy
just sacking something
to survive or
[Music]
or is there a third option
wing
wing
okay so you would like to play maybe
like a5 here and try to push
that could be but i think at the end of
the day maybe if you are really lucky in
life you're gonna push here and not lose
a pawn
but i'm not sure if you're gonna
actually get like uh
like something called counter play
but i see this
that
james and nick you guys are on fire
king f8
like you know if you are so much in
danger on the king side you just ran out
you run away like as quickly as possible
and then if you sorry i don't know why
i'm doing it if you happen to get your
king for example here
suddenly you are happy with these pieces
like defending you having actually
strong pawn structure and you are
surviving
so there are a lot of like games i think
for white when you like attack and
suddenly you move the king to the queen
side
but in this situation it's like a really
nice resourceful maneuver to just get
the king out get the king out of the g
file
yeah i think it was petrogen yeah i'm
not very good with like history and
memory so
i will i'll take you up on that orion
all right so king f8 happened i'm gonna
flip it back because we are really
interested what to do with white here
okay king f8 really smart escape we are
going h4
here going again
takes takes
97
what about now
i think this is like a critical position
that
is the hardest to play for like club
players
because we are so happy about our pawns
that they are like you know we gain so
much space the pawns are like we are
obviously better
but sometimes we kind of
over push
or sometimes we are just get too
optimistic about our position
so what to play now if you are white
bishop h5
okay
good suggestion what else
it's like improving the bishop
king g2 maybe like getting ready to
move the rules there
f6
you can gift okay great
i'm gonna give you a little more time
and everyone to
write their
ideas try to like commit to something
you know write down so like okay yeah
this is what i would play in the game
because i think you know when you
consume kind of any videos chess content
and you don't force yourself to make
decisions um you are just not gonna
actually see that improvement in your
chest too much because you're a little
bit too passive so try to like commit
okay i would play this and then we're
gonna talk about whether it's good or
not
copy black and run with the king also
so let's start with move f6
so f6 is a move that obviously if we
have an option to push and if there is a
checkmate we want to do that
the thing is that here
you know yes you are
kind of attacking the king but now you
are also opening the file and whereas
before it was like you know the pieces
couldn't get there now this rook can
get there so if you go here
um
like if you take i think you may like
right i'm just gonna knight f3 i guess
you can do but then maybe i can run
again
and still enjoy this pin
so obviously you don't have to recapture
with f after f6 maybe you can play
something else here
but
i feel like you're a sudden like
you know these pawns are amazing they
they got you you know control over let
me see here control over all these
squares and that's not it they also got
you this space for all these other
pieces you know that you can use that's
the power of the pawns because they push
forward and the black cannot get to kind
of this squares anywhere so like i like
the idea of for example king g2 just to
be happy with the pawns you know they're
good as they are they don't have to
prove anything else so far they are
awesome and then maybe figuring out how
to improve other pieces because these
pawns cleared this file so maybe now is
the time for the rook to improve
what else bishop to a4
that could be but something with the
bishop happened actually karpov decided
to play bishop g4
you wanted to say it right
so you see
more
i don't know courage or something
because you see those moves
uh bishop g4 so we are improving
you know the bishop we got the space the
pawn moves so we can get the bishop here
and now f6 maybe it's a different story
because now it could be more dangerous
because maybe we can trade the knight in
between if we want to but the important
part is you know when we have for
example the pawns right now here
just let's not like over push let's be
happy and let's improve other pieces the
pawns did their job
maybe they're gonna do more later but so
far this is enough
oh
yeah i was just going to say another
reason for is that i might want to
improve the knight as well as like let's
say
and then we're also clearing a
yep so we are really now kind of
ignoring the pawns right we are happy
what they like helped us to get but
suddenly it's time to maybe figure out
what to do with these pieces
i'm especially like thinking about what
with the h file like if we didn't get
the rooks there then that could be also
cool
okay rook g8 kind of getting ready about
the f6 so it was what wouldn't be so
that
so easy for you to play
um and white played king of two
somebody suggested that before i
remember good job you know you get one
invisible point for that
um
king f2
so now
nothing to do on g file so black is
getting to h file rook h8
rook h1 we are not going to allow that
easily
to get there
rook cg8
maybe
preparing this and just making sure
black is not going to lose also the h
file
um
queen d1
so there are other moves like for
example like actually maybe like a3
could be
interesting move to suddenly play on the
b file but let's just look you know
kind of
only in the way the game continued just
so we understand what's happening okay
black is running
um
queen g1
knight b6
h2
maybe preparing now this way to get the
h file
queen e7
now white play knight b3
so you see all the pieces now are kind
of better maybe this knight can go there
also we are putting pressure on this
pawn so if we at some moment decide to
move the king
this is
also a problem for black so black has to
figure out what to do about it
at some moment we can play f6 if we want
to
so a lot of like threats white has but
nothing specific so far
so knight b3
king c7
7
king f3 so now this is starting to be
serious we threaten to take the rook
takes and then take this pawn
97
defending the pawn absolutely logical
now your time to shine
what to do here with white
and when you suggest a move try to even
either suggest like a follow-up move or
like tell me what's the idea behind it
and please don't be shy you know there
are a lot of good ideas there are some
ideas that maybe don't make sense right
like knight a1 like who's going to
suggest that so
my goal is for you to think about good
moves i always say that i don't think
you need to play the best moves in order
to improve in chess and to win games
it's just about playing good moves and
not just playing horrible moves
so yep
um
takes h8 followed by
f6 with the idea of bishop takes
d7
okay so let's see so if we take take
f6
takes
because if you take i can recapture with
king right
and then
[Music]
okay let's look text takes here
takes
takes takes
and now if you take again the knife like
okay this bishop is still horrible i
agree with that
oh you want to attack this c5 got it
what if i
am i gonna get some
counter play no i'm gonna lose the rook
okay that was not a great suggestion
hmm
on f6
oh okay so we want to take immediately
here
okay let's let's go back just to get in
so f6
no i think i have to take
unless i want to like sacrifice
something
no it doesn't seem doesn't seem real
so
take stakes
sorry no
it takes first
take
oh what if i take with
let me think if i take with queen
you take midnight
if i give check
i mean maybe it's possible i think we
would need to spend serious time now
calculating whether it works
at first i felt like you are giving some
counter play to black which is always
something like if i have
such a great position and black doesn't
have a counter play i don't want to give
it even if even for the exchange of
getting a little bit better position but
now when i'm looking and especially
because like right this bishop and stuff
but now when i'm looking i think that
i mean it doesn't seem like black has
that much counter play and the pawn on
c5 is the problem
so i'm not fully rejecting your idea i
think it could work we just need to
calculate more
so that's one idea legit
something else
carpool was like i'm not gonna give any
counter play
i'm so happy with my pawn just you know
taking control of everything here
these pieces just having no space
whatsoever
so what is the rook what is what are
people suggesting here
all right many of you actually
uh
td1 is term d1 it's rook d1 in german
okay
rook ht1
ht1 hd2 probably
and push d6 after sacrifice okay it was
probably a different line uh rook d2
some of you want to play to think about
capturing here and here but the key move
that actually some of you mentioned
shaylash
and i think someone else a3
really cool move so the idea is now that
maybe we want to actually reshuffle to
the queen side because black got to the
king side and it looks like maybe black
is you know ready to defend there so now
we want to move to kingside because we
do have
some things happening on this and if we
can add to that maybe b file or a file
together with like knight jumping there
black is going to be in trouble
and if black will try to reshuffle all
the pieces to the queen side then maybe
we can again you know push some of the
pawns on the king's side so i think a3
is a really cool
move
and look what happened
black took
rook a2
and now rook h4
takes
black is doubling rooks but it's like
okay all you can do with the rook is to
get here
which i don't know how useful is that
or you can go here but then we're gonna
have two looks for a queen and together
with our pieces i think the two rooks
are gonna be much much better
so rook
rook b1 maybe getting ready for some
stuff like knight a5
black moved back rook b8
last move is it last move of the game
kind of last important move in this
position
although there are probably more good
moves but one move that is like
yeah principle of two weaknesses like we
could talk about the b file being weak
and the c5 yep
yep
good job james
queenie one
queen is the only piece the last piece
that can be improved right the knight is
pretty much kind of ready to jump there
being happy yup
shaylesh also queenie one so we are
attacking this rook and we are
threatening to go here and i mean
anytime we double on this file that's
just really game over
so black decided to kind of you know
desperation attack
here
and then just to like bishop c8 to
defend
and queen a5
and this is just
kind of lost so you cannot move the king
here because let's discover the attack
immediately here and checkmate
and after rook b6 i'll give you a little
bit time to calculate what to play here
so this game is scarp of gligeridge from
1972 and gligorich actually resigned
after knight a5
but let us calculate what would have
followed after rook b6
i think there are more ways also to
weigh in a bottle
okay wide to move
so i should make electron gliger best
move so we're gonna make up for
for this loss
i agree james it's a little counter
intuitive
but only to the extent like when you
realize that the pawns on the king's
side can really like
just storm in there then i think that
makes more sense
but okay we talk positional stuff now
tactics has to kick in
so who can who can find the
best continuation here
okay there there is a pin there is some
future
i don't know if the chat is stuck or you
all are writing a whole variation okay
ariane let's see knight takes c5 bishop
takes c
five
rook takes c6 bishop takes c b6
bishop takes b6 knight takes b6 and c5
actually that's
that's very correct
that's perfect perfect calculation so
let's look at that knight takes c5 now
if knight takes then obviously we take
here
i wonder if we take with rook no we take
we take with queen and this is just
winning
okay so they have to take with bishop
now i can imagine that many of you may
be considered capturing the bishop
but then the queen captures and like the
knight is defending the queen and the
queen is now with the knight and king
defending the rook and everything is
safe
so that's why we have to start with
rook takes rook
now if knight takes then we are
capturing with bishop and getting this
guy as well
and if they take with bishop which seems
very logical now we trade the bishop
knight takes and plays c5
almost four connects almost
um but mainly just getting the knight
now
so it's completely winning so now when
we go back completely to this position
i think it's really nice to just think
like okay first we do this in power move
c4 to block this guy here and just not
allow any counter play because let's say
we start reshuffling our knight like if
they get to play c4
then like they develop the bishop like
it's completely different story right
suddenly pushing here maybe doing
something there
and black is kind of breathing
so that's why we play c4
and then we just prepare the attack
that's not what happened
97 that's also not what happened because
that's helping the knight
let me find the
move that happened queen c2
close the position and then this really
cool i think knight e2 move
and suddenly we go with the pawns and
the rest i think all of you remember the
critical moment is again i think
somewhere here where we are very happy
with our pawns everybody feels that
white is better
but just now is the time to slow down
and think about other pieces
so what happened was like moving this
this this this sorry here and then at
the end actually opening up here
awesome okay
what time is it do we have time for one
more yeah we do
right
no
ten minutes yeah
so let's
next game let's think about
this position so i will tell you that
today we are talking about kind of
getting space with pawns
so here in this position again first we
kind of need to
like settle in figure out what's
happening and
realize that black is pawn up
but for that pawn
white has some developmental advantage
right the bishops are
kind of active having some potential the
rook is very cool here and we have two
center pawns
all right so you got all that so now the
question is
what to do next
so right now i want you to think about
again two three
move candidates
it's always the same thing with me
nothing too creative
yep james suggesting e5 or d5 definitely
moves we have to consider
okay it's coming
because this pawn is obviously hanging
right so e5 makes sense so now e5 so
what is e5 doing so e5 is
blocking this bishop right when we push
it this bishop is kind of
looking at this pawn which is not not
that great for it so
that's good it also opens up this bishop
right
what is the drawback of e5
what do you think black is going to play
after e5
yep
so we play e5 black responds with knight
c6
and now this pawn is a target
and i want to play maybe rook d8 next
and just simply capture it
so e5 knight c6 and obviously if you
capture this knight then like you're
let's look at that
so my goal is to go here and just put
more pressure
and if you decide to do this then
i mean you get out you give up your
advantage of having pair of bishops
i'm probably going to take this ways
so i'm yeah pawn up
it's not a great pawn but i'm still
happy
so
well if you play d5 to attack the knight
then this pawn is not defended and i
will just take it
so unless we have another move candidate
then let's talk about d5
so what is the advantage and what is the
disadvantage of d5
very good so d5 to even like spell it
out controls this square suddenly right
also this and especially it doesn't
allow knight to jump there
so it gets more space because we are
certainly entering the black's camp and
we are not allowing the finish of
development
the downside is that maybe we are
blocking the bishop a bit more so it's
definitely something we have to consider
but if we have to choose between
obviously these two moves
then d5 makes
more sense and actually d5 is a pretty
good move here so let's see what
happened in the game
so d5
hikaru developed knight a6
queen e2
finishing development
nothing too fancy knight c5
e5
now this is pretty cool so suddenly this
bishop is no longer that blocked
we have really strong pawns
and like they're controlling all these
squares
rook ae8
so black is kind of getting ready to
you know for the
for stuff happening on the king side or
kind of in the center
rook fd1
not being you know overly ambitious
about other like pawn pushes just
finishing development
f6
now this is kind of obviously this is
like grand masters playing so some of
the moves are not so obvious to to see
um like here some people could think
about maybe like capturing but obviously
this is like very bad because we are
opening up the file
and getting rid of our kind of connected
pawns
so instead there is this quick move
very important of bishop e3 but move
that i think is kind of hard to see
rook c8
your time to shine
white to move
what to do next
i mean black's idea is pretty i mean
pretty simple right we just want to grab
this guy
maybe i'm not sure if it's
that could be a thread also okay maybe
it's not that
not that simple but bishop g4 is not
definitely possible immediately because
then we can we can push if we want to
yep okay
james edwin you guys are really strong
um
queen a2 is a very nice idea so
that's why d6 is actually super strong
move good job for everyone thinking
about this move so these things helps us
to open the file whenever we are ready
opens up this diagonal but also opens up
this diagonal when whenever we need it
so we're like
2x clan move d6 very strong
black played
b6 move here
because if we play e takes d6
queen a to check really strong
here
and we
take this guy and the problem is that
everything is falling apart
because now we are threatening to
capture this knight for free because
this is a this is a pin and we are also
threatening to capture here
and then take the knight as well
so this is now just very very
problematic
so when you can do that when you can't
take on d6 because of the strong queen
a2
i mean you are you are in serious
trouble
b6
i think this is your last time to shine
in this game
so let's use it
what to do here
with white pieces
because obviously we get the feeling
that the pawns are great our position is
good but now is the time when we need to
close on positions that are better
which is a very difficult task
okay so james and so e6 so what's your
idea e6 if i take
oh i'm just blind blind okay so i can do
that
so e6 if i take this way
yep exactly so i think if i go here i
think i can take i cannot take with the
queen as i want it to
because then there is this bishop defy
really strong pin
so
but we can take probably i mean i'm a
little afraid just a little bit but i
think i'm surviving
yeah
yep very good so we do want to push the
pawn but first we just straight back and
obviously we don't like to give up you
know the pair of bishops but now we have
a direct plan what we want to do so
bishop takes c5 rook takes c5 e6 i mean
look at those pawns they started here
and now they're both there that's
actually you're correct okay
um all right queen c8
no that's not t8
queen c8
d takes e7
because the problem is if you move here
like i'm gonna do the same thing and
then i'm gonna
go rogue d7
and then i'm just gonna here and this
one is just gonna be extremely extremely
strong
and you can really go and like try to
take this
because wait am i
am i going to go like here
[Music]
because i want to do something here and
something there
but let me look at the lines i'm not
lying to you
yeah okay so here and if you now go this
way obviously this is a big problem
and if you capture with queen
i'm gonna go probably
how is this one in queen c7
thank you thank you today yeah just
trading trading bishop d5
that's correct
okay
so that doesn't work
so black is trying to say you know i'm
just going to play here queen c8 and
kind of ignore that you have a double
pawn
so that's what happened so
queen c8 takes 7
here
now rook d8
queen takes pushing even more
here and now this is the moment where
still precision is very very important
so some of you could think about you
know rook d1 or rookie one probably
rugby one makes more sense but it's the
best to start immediately with rook e6
because queen f7 doesn't work we want to
promote so king has to move
now we go rogue d1
why not pawn d7 because this is just
winning like kind of in a forceful way
and last move of the game
what did johannes plays played against
hikaru nakamura in 2002 here
yep
very good queen take c8 and
did he resign here actually let me see
uh
no queen takes c8 rook d8
and now just black resign because there
is nothing else to do so again when we
go all the way back
to here
this looks like a you know normal kind
of position from greenfield white is
spawned down but it's like really cool
move d5 just controlling this space
and then pushing with these pawns
bringing you know these pieces here
suddenly it feels like it's so natural
like so easy to be grandmaster right so
easy to make those moves but sometimes
like we like try to push too quickly or
something so like yes we want to push
with pawns but then we want to make sure
that we are following up with pieces
now that's not what we want to do
so we moved back
and now this i mean most like d6 that's
when like you know strategy and tactics
it's important to do both because when
you get a strategically good position
that's when tactical threats or tactical
motives appear and you need to find them
so i really recommend doing tactics but
it's important to
to know strategy as well because then
you have the thing of like you know
naturally moving pieces like moving like
rook and d1 like you would be like
surprised how often like analyzing
someone's game and they just never move
the rook from a1 or they start like oh i
want to play like g4 and attack there
and then i don't know queen is somewhere
there not even like improved so think
about like the pieces to really be more
in kind of unison when creating an
attack here you see it's like rugano
files bishops ready queen also it's hard
to find a better spot now when the pawn
moves okay yeah maybe the queen is
better here
but other than that everything is pretty
pretty perfect
awesome so thank you so much everyone
for being here by the way all these
examples were from book mastering chess
strategy by johann helston i think the
book is pretty pretty fantastic
and it has only like it's about strategy
in chess so it has a lot of chapters to
focus on you know specific things so i
highly recommend it
thank you so much for you know
suggesting stuff here i'm always happy
when the
lecture is kind of interactive and when
it's just not me and just saying
everything but you guys are
participating as well so thank you so
much
and see you on thursday
bye everyone
[Music]
you